je vous écris qu'on était tous dans la
loge et forcément il ya toujours un mec
qui fait le malin mais qu'on fait mal a
bizarrement c'est toujours marrant moi
qui serai toujours un hommage à mike est
à 10 il a voulu fall main il a voulu me
battre au ping pong mais je dit écoutez
on va attendre et je vous proposer
quelque chose ce soir en direct à tout
de suite vous pouvez miser sur benjamin
castaldi on va faire un match en trois
points dakar 4 points 5 points 5 3 6 6 1
54.47 moins 8 mois 3 0 on devrait être
en vacances en france on est là on bosse
et on a plein d'infos je suis prêt à
payer 10 contre 1 tous les chroniqueurs
cd rom était un euro sur castaldi nous
en donne 10 ha ouais vous en mettez 10
vous en donne sens dans m'étais san jose
en 2000 exemple et émile je parte
[Rires]
si vous perdez tout l'argent je prendrai
la personne qui aura fait le hashtag
benjamin castaldi est une banane n'est
pas un hashtag grenelle est une maladie
et je lui offrirai tout l'argent que
j'aurais récoltés je suis un petit peu
ric-rac mais je peux comme des rats mais
naim donc un sac banane julien courbet
cinq balles dont je paie mon ticket de
métro
oh non mais aucun de ces valeurs home
cinéma mais je connais la valeur d'un
licenciement konya halal et non halal et
abréger que ça je bous loin je suis trop
de l'agglo à aller chercher l'argent au
distributeur
je les ai perdus mais je suis prêt à
miser de nouveau 5 euros donc si tu
gagnes tu calmes 50 balles près d'accord
bon j'ai que deux tu crois qu'ils ne
passaient pas d'argent cinq balles mais
des aides culinaires de losail là bas je
peut te [ __ ] ou
le bal de la wii mais si j'ai plus je
donne plus est lui à mon avis frère non
là sur moi et je t'offre une séance d'uv
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
joffre joffre dix fois le montant total
aux gens qui nous regardent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention c'est un 5-3 aux tirs voilés
servi on voulait que je sers allez je
vous en prie
enlève plutôt slip
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mentalement et très faible tu as eu un
truc bien tu vois toi tu joues bien mais
tu un souci à une secte ou animaux
écoute pas l'écoutent pas pour ça que tu
dis voir souvent espère bien pour un bon
[ __ ] mais c'est pas tout mais vous
n'avez pas de mental castaldi flics et
aussi les quatre points alors
franchement j'ai trois paradis perdu non
c'est la sauvette proposent un truc je
vais prendre mon iphone j'ai c'est de
marquer le dernier point l'iphone bâle
est ok t'as pas un gros le groupe je
vous donne joue pas mieux avec sa valise
un bébé ça va le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci messieurs